are you looking for something to do this
winter break there's one local company
that has customizable flight lessons
with only one requirement
you gotta go all in las vegas
we go all in on the strip and in the sky
you're here at all in aviation at our
brand new facility at the henderson
executive airport
we rent exclusively cirrus aircraft it's
the most technologically advanced
safest airplane ever made and we've got
nine of them available for people to
learn how to fly and to rent
now i'm not quite ready to rent but i am
ready to learn and apparently i'm not
alone
during cobit 19 flying commercial has
obviously taken a dive but
flying private is on the rise we
actually have been busier than we've
ever been
believe it or not i think people have
given themselves
permission to spend a little bit more
than they would have
on travel so that they can keep their
family their associates their work
colleagues a little bit safer so we've
actually seen a big uptick in people
that
are buying airplanes that are learning
how to fly and take advantage of
of all the the beautiful things that
you're going to see here when we fly
together
okay we'll get to those beautiful things
from the sky but first
the technical things from the ground so
let's walk around here we check out the
tail
we see that our elevator is secure but
the most important thing on a serious
airplane the most unique
is that we got a parachute safety system
paul says the fear of flying actually
alleviates when you're at the controls
and honestly
he's right i want you to get the feel
for this so go ahead and turn the
controls all the way to the left
so we go all the way left as soon as i
sat down
i was all in here for takeoff 365 816
lima papa
smoothly advance that power all the way
forward i gotcha
listen kitty up and let's go all the way
forward all the way
all right so we're looking for 73 we've
already got 50. right here
right here perfect so just be careful
when you pull back only with the stick
not with your hand
okay and there's 73-76 go ahead and pull
this off the ground
oh my god
[Music]
see i wanted to keep climbing so push
forward just a little bit
wow
you did that let's keep that turn coming
to the right
this is all you wow i'm flying a plane
you are you're doing great
[Music]
yep so everybody is required by the fa
to do 40 hours of flight time
that is the minimum i would say the
average ends up being about 65 hours
of actual time in the airplane well only
39 more hours to go
so this is your first official pilot
logbook entry so we flew eight one
system of papa for nine tenths of an
hour
uh from henderson airport and this quite
literally will count towards those 40
hours of
flight training that you need to become
a pilot so congratulations thank you for
going all in
wow that was so cool to relive i mean
that was definitely one of my favorite
moments of 2020
i'm just wondering would you guys let me
fly you
they're shaking no come on